a few weeks ago we met Amari he's 11 in
the soft-spoken kid who loves video
games YouTube and basketball and we met
Amari while doing some research on
emerging technologies so we sat down
with Ahmadi and a couple of his friends
in a modest dining room and basically
just asked him about the future where
he'd like to go and what he'd like to do
here's what he said bring me my dog and
teleport an ice-cream shop we've all
been there we've all dreamt about the
future I certainly remember being a
Marty's age and dreaming about flying
cars and robots that cater to my every
need we're dreaming about where new
technology would would go and where it
would take me and when you dream of the
future what do you see do you dream
about concurrent odometry and horizontal
plane detection do you fantasize about
hot words and utterance capture all
about maybe in this group here today at
play time perhaps but at the world at
large probably not more likely we dream
about the places we can go the things we
can do and the people we can be I'm
France
this is Fabian and we're from I do I do
is a global design and innovation firm
and I do pioneered human centered design
which is a philosophy and approach
towards design which always starts with
people's desires and it's really the
only way for us how we get inspired
about future products and services and
we're here today to talk about how in
our experience technology is always the
most valuable when it helps us actually
realize our dreams
and we really want to shift the thinking
from what technology is capable of to
what it enables us as humans to do and
these four emerging technologies are on
everybody lips today it's like we are
they are digital assistants and of
course as well apps and if we talk about
apps we're talking about that kind of
app that you don't have to download and
install we will call them ephemeral apps
now these technologies are becoming
increasingly important computing
platforms and none of us want to miss
out on the opportunities they represent
and some of you may already be working
with these technologies and some of you
may be considering working with them and
you may be thinking to yourself I'd like
to get involved but I don't know how and
if I jump in and get involved
what should I build what should I make
with these technologies and I'm sure
you're all asking yourself how does any
of this fit into my business and how am
I going to make money so today here at
playtime we heard a lot about the
capabilities of those technologies about
their features and how to implement them
so we are not going to talk about any of
that what we are going to talk about is
actually what are these technology is
good for from a human perspective how do
they fit into your business and how you
can get started and of course most
importantly how can we all learn
something from amadi and it's golden
flying Lamborghini now earlier this year
Google Play approached us and they post
a pretty great question they asked us
what are these technologies really good
for now we're really excited by them and
we know they have a ton of potential but
what do people actually want to do with
them and how can we help our developer
partners that's all of you here today
how can we help them
make the most of these technologies and
to answer the question we did what we
always do we went out and talked to
people first we talked to the people on
the forefront of those technologies
researchers developers some of you guys
here in the audience because we really
want to understand what are the people
that are developing and creating with
those technologies have been actually
thinking about them and then we went and
spoke to both users and non-users of
these technologies because we wanted to
learn how people imagine these four
things fitting into their everyday lives
what their what their hopes and dreams
are when it comes to these technologies
and to do this we hosted a number of
group research sessions and our offices
in San Francisco the same themes kept
coming up so we're going to give you a
peek into one of these sessions and for
this particular session we invited five
people among them a self-identified
early adopter a gamer and even a
complete technophobe so just let you
know if we do this kind of sessions we
like to recruit for the extreme of
behaviors so that we really span the
full spectrum of experiences with any
given subject and it's really important
for us that we have strong inspiring
opinions and perspectives to push our
thinking and as you can see it's a very
casual in-person conversation over beers
so no one-way mirror is a fancy tracking
technology because again the intention
was not to be comprehensive here the
intention was to really understand what
people are feeling and what they want
what they do and why and we didn't want
to get distracted by some of the
existing platforms or brands or products
and so in order to do that we created a
number of design exercises that
abstracted each technology into
something that people could hold draw on
and use to start imagining the potential
because we found that if you give
something to people that's too polished
they'll look for the flaws but if you
give them something that's pretty rough
they can begin to see the potential
so let's look at take a look at what we
did for vrv exercise we did for Vyasa to
dig into people's dreams for VR we
handed out different scenes that ranged
from the mundane like commuting on the
subway to the more fantastical like
visiting Mars or flying over a city we
told people to imagine that they were
transported to this place then we asked
them how do you think you got there what
would you do there who or what would you
want to bring along who would you want
to communicate with and we also chatted
with our group about AR and to access
their hopes for the future of AR we did
another simple exercise we just handed
out this piece of acrylic to lay over
their scenes and asked them to draw what
they imagined seen through those magic
glasses that's how we call them here's
what they came up with and when we play
this video about AR and VR please pay
close attention to what are their wishes
I mean listen to what they're saying but
also what are the desires and wishes
implicit in their words I'm underwater
scuba diving I'm in downtown Tokyo I am
on the New York subway
I'm currently skydiving over San
Francisco I was in a meeting and I was
really bored so I decided to come to
Mars I am probably with my
seven-year-old this guy looks like he
could be a famous rock star and it'd be
really cool if I could validate that
somehow my magic glasses allow me to
share this experience with my followers
in real time
over here we have the donations that are
coming in live as my viewers like what
I'm doing so here you see a notification
Lena wants to join me on my quest to
find them watch treasure my magic
glasses have two modes one is all about
me and one is all about them so for the
me mode it would show me recommendations
and news feed and then for them I would
be able to understand how my fellow
commuters are doing what they're
thinking what they're feeling and what
they might need okay in the corner you
can see that I have a countdown to when
my pizza
arrives in the real world and in fact I
would want the ability to almost dismiss
all of it and like better immerse myself
in the environment so Nikki wanted to
bring her kids along with her to Tokyo
and Angela wanted to find out about that
potential rock star in the subway and
when we hear Susannah say that she was
in a boring meeting and escaped to Mars
to find hidden treasure with her friend
Lena we listen to that story we don't
tend to fixate on whether her VR headset
is going to make her nauseous or how
she's going to be able to pick up
Martian rocks using motion controllers
and don't get us wrong sure we know that
all those technical constraints are
important but what people are actually
saying is that they want to escape to an
exciting place they want to explore this
place on their own terms and they want
to share their experiences with friends
so at its core for us the promise of VR
is the ability to take us to amazing new
places with new abilities that are only
limited by our imagination now we heard
from another person that they were
playing Pokemon go during their commute
and in doing so they began to notice all
these wonderful architectural details in
the New York subway that they'd missed
before if you think about that story in
the context of a yawn if you go beyond
the surface what people want from AR is
to learn about their surroundings and
the people within them so in other words
the overarching promise of AR is that it
gives us the ability to reveal and
interact with hidden layers of
information right within our physical
surroundings ok now let's look at
digital assistance and to uncover
thoughts and digital assistance we did
another very simple exercise we just
asked the the group to basically write a
job description for a real-life
assistant and we asked them like if you
would have this assistant like what
would you ask them to do which kind of
skills do they need to have I think most
importantly
which kind of relationship do you want
to have with this assistant here's what
they said I'm looking for somebody who's
very organized self-starter able to
predict my needs be able to keep my kids
entertained without screen time I would
say think Tony Stark and pepper and iron
man
she knows what he needs before he needs
it and I would definitely look for a
willingness to challenge my ideas and
propose like new or novel solutions keep
me on track and honest with a lot of my
personal goals if they could show me a
funny animal video every day I would be
very happy
the unusual trait is that this person
never ever sleeps so people wanted their
assistant to go far beyond just simple
tasks automation or delegation they
wanted their assistant to inspire them
to motivate them to keep them honest and
to make them laugh in other words what
they wanted their system to be is to be
very personable and they wanted to
interact with them in very human terms
through natural conversation so if we
think about digital assistants we really
need to think about their potential
which is that they can support us in
very empathic and kind of very intuitive
ways so they can respond to our mood to
our context and sometimes even challenge
and surprise us so the promise of
digital assistants is to be able to
control information in a very intuitive
way through conversations and we're very
excited about what that could mean for
conversational interfaces and especially
for the expression of personality
through this technology now finally
we're going to talk about apps a subject
you're all very familiar with now the
introduction of ephemeral apps prompted
us to revisit how people approach apps
in the context of what they want to do
not just how they want to do it
so we basically presented people with
two scenarios one was
Kaffir a new cafe opened near your
workplace anyone to order something
there and the second one is you have to
park a car in the city that you haven't
visited before and then be again like we
just asked them how they would do this
in an ideal world what the challenge is
coming up in how they would go about it
let's take a look what they said I would
like to pull up some sort of interface
that will just magically show up and
have a level of like social proof or
validation that this Cafe is actually
good if I had a coffee around the
specific time of day you should just ask
me do you want me to order your coffee I
would like to at least do it with
minimal human interaction and with as
few steps as possible so things like
payment information is already saved
what would be nice some sort of alert or
my assistant telling me hey you know
what it's ten minutes past the time
you're allowed to park here don't park
here there's another spot ten minutes
away it all just automatically detect
when my car has parked and then when
I've actually left actually what I would
want to do is I want to pull up and have
my car let me out and then it would
drive off
don't make me park and behind the future
that he imagines really is a request and
the request is that he doesn't want to
deal with the task of parking his car he
just wants to get on with his day and
you heard another person say that he
wanted to order food from the new cafe
with minimal human interaction and with
as few steps as possible what he's
really saying is just make it easy and
simple for me so if we talk about
ephemeral apps or about all apps for
that matter people aren't really that
interested in which platform or service
they are interacting with they just want
to do what they do when they need to and
it should be as simple delightful and
intuitive as possible and to be fair I
mean there has been the promise of apps
all along right now we had one more
group session this one was with kids you
heard from Amari on his Lamborghini
right in the beginning
we held a session with a group of kids
aged 10 and 11 and we spoke to them
about the four same technologies and
their dreams for the future when it
comes to these technologies we did the
same for design research exercises with
them with with one exception instead of
a human assistant personal assistant we
asked them to design their very own
personal robot because well hey why not
and again we didn't look for inspiration
from kids because they're gonna be the
core demographic of what we're doing
here but we asked kids because they have
the ability to imagine and dream
unhindered of any constraints of
technological or historical baggage and
they really did so let's see what they
imagined it has stretch marks on its leg
because it can be as small as fitting in
your pocket and as big as a human it
makes gummies for me in its stomach it
rests underneath my bed and it's my
alarm I was transported to Tokyo Japan
and I got here by taking my private jet
I like to bring my robot my friends my
family and does tons of other things
including a device that I imagined that
would be a translator that I put in my
ear and I would translate Japanese so
what does all of this really mean I know
cute kids and all but what did we learn
at a high level from our research well
if you take a step back
fundamentally the promise of all new
technology has always been to expand our
abilities as humans to enable us to do
things that we weren't able to do before
so it's never just been about what the
technology is capable of but more
importantly it's been about what it
enables us to do as people and that's a
very important distinction and these
four technologies we've been speaking
about
of us fantastic new your bilities and i
think that's why we're all so excited by
them but sometimes when we're exploring
the features and specs and capabilities
of these technologies we can lose track
of what they actually fundamentally mean
for people we can get frustrated by the
shortcomings of the current incarnation
of these technologies especially when
the frameworks works are still new and
we're all trying to figure things out
together so here's the summary of the
four technologies and what they enable
us to do and what people are expecting
from them so VR should transport us to
different places with new abilities of
mantid reality allows us to interact
with hidden layers of information in our
physical surrounding while digital
assistant let us access and control
information and services through
conversation and ephemeral apps make it
easy for us to do what we want when we
want and it's again it's really
important that when we develop for those
technologies that we keep the human
story in mind we really need to ask
ourselves is if what we are doing is in
service of the desires and dreams of the
people that were designing for because
if you start with what people want and
not what's technically possible I think
you have an approach that increases the
likelihood of really creating something
meaningful desirable and of lasting
value ok so right about now you may be
thinking interesting cool that's great
but how do I apply this to my business
how do I apply this to my particular
case and my customer well we've got
something for you if you reach
underneath your seats you'll find a deck
of cards glued to the bottom of your
chairs for the people on the wooden
chairs they're glued to the legs pop up
is like popcorn
right open open the deck of cards up and
we'll go through them together and we'll
explain them to you so we've called this
deck of cards human-centered design
prompts for emerging technologies and
the deck contains twenty prompts
spanning the four technologies we've
been talking about and they're there to
help you think of potential products in
the context of your own particular
customers needs they're based on our
research on what we heard people want
and they're intended to provide guidance
at that earlier ideation stage when
you're trying to figure out what to
build as Ross talked about earlier so
here's how these cards work you remember
Garrett who earlier talked about his
magical assets what he really wanted is
the ability to dismiss everything and
better immerse himself in the
environment so he's basically asking for
a mute button to avoid any distraction
and that made us think a our might have
the ability to help people focus and
that's not typically what we think about
right when we think about AR it's always
about adding stuff about augmenting
reality but what if we use it to remove
things and to enhance focus so is there
an opportunity to help prioritize
information in our environment through
AR so say you picked up this card and it
says think of a moment in your users day
when they're overwhelmed or distracted
now consider your particular user their
day-to-day life and could that be a
certain time of day or maybe it's a
certain type of situation they're in you
picture that scenario in your mind and
then you flip the card over to the
design prompt which reads how might we
use AR to remove distractions so we'll
give you an example so you know how this
works so say you're a physical retailer
and when a customer walks into your
store they're faced with hundreds
possibly even thousands of different
products and
at times your user may be browsing and
they may just be roaming the store but
at other times they may actually know
exactly what they want and in those
cases entering a store may be a very
overwhelming and and distracting
experience so you could consider
creating an AR application that helps
your customer find exactly what they
want by simply removing what they don't
now that's just an example there's a
clear product opportunity there but you
can see how there's a very human desire
in this case the need to focus that can
be met using a AR and what we are doing
here is basically we're finding a design
opportunity which leads with a human
scenario and a need and desire so we
didn't choose the technology first we
didn't say which kind of AR application
can we build we basically asked how can
we help people focus and AR might be one
technology that does that and in doing
this exercise in using these cards you
may also find that actually some of
these technologies don't lend themselves
to your business and your customer and
that maybe they're not worth pursuing
and that's fine too at least by doing it
this way you didn't commit months of
resources to it before finding out the
pardon well frankly expensive way okay
let's look at another one something sue
Susan said about her personal assistant
she said she wants it to make make her
laugh-in sarcastic and make sarcastic
remarks so that make us think like if
those digital assistants should have
really human meaningful conversations
they me really need to understand the
mood of the person they're talking to or
as Rupert put it sometimes I want to
have a discussion with it sometimes I
wanted to give me some attitude and
sometimes I just wanted to turn off the
damn lights so here's the corresponding
card think of a moment in your users day
when their mood might change so consider
it is that when
transitioning between different
behaviors or perhaps they're moving
between different places or it's
dependent on who they're with you
picture the scenario you flip the card
over to the design prompt how might we
adapt the digital assistance tone and
behavior to the user's mood so let's say
your company that basically delivers
personalized news value assistant so you
can imagine that somebody getting ready
for work in the morning during a weekday
wants very different information and has
delivered in a very different way than
let's say on a Sunday afternoon and I
think it might be that they want more
inspirational stories they want to have
more account of a conversation with
their with their assistant and then the
question is like how does the assistant
actually participate in this
conversation
and the opportunity is quite literal
it's you can give you brand a voice in
personality and considering that you
uses mood changes throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the year
your brand should adapt to that right
and I mean that's for us the only way
how you can have like a human meaningful
conversation and also a long lasting
relationship with people so those are
just two examples of the set of twenty
cards you have in your hands and we hope
you take these cards and some of the
methods we shared with you today and use
them as a starting point
imagining entirely new products features
and potentially even entirely new
businesses surrounding these
technologies because getting started
with these technologies can be
intimidating but we believe it doesn't
have to be complicated or expensive yeah
we just didn't encourage you to build
those scrappy prototypes and go out and
talk to customers because that's the
only way how we'll find out about the
dreams
I mean dreams aren't made of specs and
features SDKs and api's dreams are
inherently human and it's something
that's deep inside of all of us so when
building with emerging technologies
start there
start with the dreams of those you're
actually designing for
and also sometimes don't forget to tap
into your own dreams we're very excited
to see what you come up with and what
you create thank you
you